あの最近やけに空に向かおうとしてる自分がいます
うん
今回はちょっと続けて上に行く系なんですけど、も
風船ヘリコプター、組立カンタン。
まあ見たらわかると思うんですけども
風船つけると空に飛んでくヘリコプターでございます
ビュッ(?)ナッナッ
ﾋﾟｭｰﾝ
ピューン（２回目）
って書いてある
動画公開されてるらしいですね
で、作り方は超カンタンで
組み立てて膨らませてくっつけたら
飛んでいくってやつでございます
ちょっとやってみましょう・。・
もうできた×4
膨らまして
ブえっうフェフェフェフェ
よし、これを空気が抜けないように
プロペラにつけたら飛んでいく...?
あ、OKOKもういけるもういｋもういくよもういくよ
もういくよ、も×3 もう飛びます×2
こわっ
うわっ
ムズイ×2、これムズイよ
あ、きた×3
Pーーーーーーーーー【風船の空気が抜ける音】
待って×4
ちょっともうちょい行くと思う、もう一回やってみます
あ、ﾋﾟｭｰﾝってそうゆーことなのね
きた×3
行きます×3
Pーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーー
待って×3、しょうもなくね？
ｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
はい、というわけで、しょうもな...
これ何がしょうもないかっていうと、たぶん
風船自体が小さいから、しょうもないと私は思った
ので今回、巨大な風船を準備しました
これぐらいなら膨らましたら相当デカイと思います
ｵｴ､ｵｴｰｰｰ(苦しそうに)
ゴムくさっ
一回膨らましてみるね？
うわっ、きたねえ、とんだｗｗ
ｗｗｗｗｗ
ちょ、汚い汚いｗｗｗｗｗ
はい、というわけで見てもらった通りぃ
この風船の部分に大きな風船をつけると、
めちゃくちゃ飛ぶんじゃないか、という僕の、
予想でございます
ま、大気圏ぐらいには行きたいっすね
はい、とう言うわけでデカめの風船を付けると
メチャクチャ飛ぶんじゃないかという予想でございます。
一回やってみましょう
フーーー
フーフー【風船の空気を入れる音】
何が原因？
何？場所が悪かったのかな？
多すぎたかな？
これじたいが、なんつうのかな？かっ・・稼働的に回転するわけじゃないもんね
無理だよじゃあ
あの
赤い風船は、
口が大きすぎるのと、
風船事態がおもすぎて飛ばなかったんで
ちょっと中間を取って
このサイズの風船で膨らませてみます。
コレだとタぶん
コレだったら多分飛ぶ気がします。
膨らませます
まじで、コレで飛ばなかったら今日の企画どうする？
終わりだよ
終わりですよ
でかいっしょ！
行けるぞ
コレ行ける行ける！
これマジで行ける！！
いける✕3
はい！
じゃあいきます！！
いきます✕3
Pーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーー【空気が抜ける音】
【はじめナレーション】男は諦らめずに
何度も
風船を大気圏に飛ばそうとしたが・・・
無理だった・・・
そして最後には・・・
悲劇が男を襲った・・・
パン！【風船が割れる音】
テレッテテッテ↓テレッテっッテッ↓テッテッテッテ
テー↑テレレ↑レレーレー
テレレれーテレレレーレー
テレレレーレーレレ
テレレテーレーレー
てってってって
ぺ　ぺ　ぺ　ぺ
パチコーン【風船が割れる音】